a blurry photograph of a man in a Black
Cowl is taped to the wall a black knife
held by a tattooed hand pierces his face
you want him dead a blast dealt with his
foundation Handler replied same thing
Abel said and laughed the helicopter was
ready to go outside it was another rainy
night almost all of them were plumes of
black smoke billowing from factories on
the far side of the city blotting out
the already darkened sky and plunging
Gotham into deeper Shadow but those
Shadows that Darkness were something
that Twisted underbelly had come to fear
the dark was a tool that one man used to
prey on those who enacted Injustice on
the innocent every shadowy alley or a
flutter of movement atop a roof made
every thief and murder on the streets of
Gotham take pause think twice Batman had
been trailing the movements of
suspicious cargo trucks moving in and
out of the city some were decoys driving
around with empty containers and
changing their routes every night to
throw the world's greatest detective off
the trail but those were just a
distraction a theatrical deception being
deployed so that the real cargo could be
smuggled in undetected Bane a
muscle-bound mercenary with the guise of
a Luchador was one of Batman's most
physically imposing enemies for weeks he
had been stockpiling Venom a strength
enhancing compound somewhere in the city
and now Batman had picked up the trail
the trucks weren't Distributing the
Venom that was being done by a network
of low-level street thugs posing as
motorcycle delivery drivers swooping
through the night sky watching one of
the bikers from above there was
something else playing on the dark
Knight's mind recently he'd gotten the
feeling he was being watched at first
the man under the cowl billionaire
philanthropist Bruce Wayne had chalked
it up to paranoia a side effect of his
nightly escapades as the cape Crusader
is trusted Butler and Confidant Alfred
had even suggested as much but as the
weeks rolled on Batman couldn't shrug
the notion that every move he made every
case he helped Commissioner Gordon solve
every battle with the worst of Gotham's
Rogues gallery that somebody was
studying him already Bruce had a list of
potential suspects the likely candidates
for who were having him followed so he
gradually began paying them all visits
as his alter ego the larger of the
city's mob families the falcones denied
any involvement with their leader
Carmine Falcone currently Behind Bars
the rest of the family were laying low
to avoid being arrested themselves next
came Hugo Strange a brilliant but
unhinged scientist who had become
obsessed with Batman for a number of
years Bruce had worried that Hugo had
finally cracked the secret of his true
identity but the Despicable doctor also
refused that he was the one having the
Dark Knight followed the next possible
culprit on this list was Amanda Waller a
powerful and high-ranking government
operative strategic genius and another
of Batman's Rivals known to some as the
wall she was responsible for a number of
shady covert operations that not even
the cape Crusader knew about Waller
dealt in secrets and seemed just as
likely to be having Batman tailed in
order to pick up dirt on the detective
but as with strange and the falcones
Amanda Waller denied all of the dark
Knight's claims the heartbeat scanners
built into his cow's eyepieces confirmed
that they had all been telling the truth
shrugging the notion off Batman focused
on following the biker transporting
Venom across the city silently gliding
between skyscrapers with his cape he
followed The Smuggler all the way to an
abandoned chemical processing plant
formerly owned by a company called Ace
chemical he suspected that was where
Bane and his thugs had established a
base of operations using the plants
leftover equipment to refine the Venom
the source of veins in human strength
scanning through the rooftop with his
cow's x-ray capabilities from a distance
Batman spotted a group of armed men
unloading the boxes they were acting
under the command of a larger figure
Bane himself but then a new unidentified
figure had appeared and come striding
into the building met with hostility as
Bane's forces Drew their weapons whoever
this was he clearly wasn't with them
suddenly just as Batman fired his
grappling hook to swing onto the roof of
the chemical plant all out chaos erupted
inside down below watching intently by
Batman as he slipped inside staying
concealed in the rafters the new figure
had begun violently attacking Bane and
his men the man was lean shirtless
around his late 20s with gray eyes and a
mess of jet black hair his entire body
was covered in tattoos depicting Arcane
ruins and occult imagery on his olive
skin and His Hands had appeared a pair
of sharp black blades seemingly from
nowhere to some he was heevelban Adam
The Butcher of the West the great
traitor and first sword of Davon but to
the ones that had sent him there he was
scp-076-2 able he charged towards the
group of thugs as they opened fire their
bullets missing as Abel moved with
Incredible speed with a strong upward
swing of both his swords he cleaved the
nearest two mercenaries weapons into
broken pieces as if their guns were made
of plastic not metal Abel brought both
swords slicking downwards felling both
men simultaneously another nearby turned
and ran only to be caught by one of
Abel's blades as the barbaric Warrior
hurled it through the air watching from
above Batman was taken aback it was rare
for him to be so alarmed by a display of
violence especially given he had devoted
his life to crime fighting but the
figure below was taking on Bane's men
single-handedly with such speed and
aggression but it gave the cape Crusader
pause as much as he abhorred killing
Batman held back to observe this new
adversary as Abel squared up against
Bane himself the Luchador charged at him
with the unbridled Rage of a snarling
feral animal while Abel leaped into
battle with equal ferocity his hand
reached into a tiny dimensional Rift a
hole in space out from which he
retrieved an extra weapon that he swung
directly at Bane's head the imposing
muscle monster caught the blade in this
huge hand blocking the blow he lifted
Abel off the ground his own hand
gripping the sword by its Hilt and was
about to deliver a crippling punch that
would have sent the Barbarian flying
that is had he not slipped another sword
seemingly out of thin air and used it to
slice through the blade that Bane had in
his grip Batman had only ever seen
combatants with Abel's level of fighting
prowess among the ranks of the court of
owls and League of Assassins ancient
orders of killers who operated in secret
maybe this barbaric fighter was part of
such an organization maybe Abel had been
watching him the detective watched and
pondered over possible connections to
Ra's al Ghul Talon and even Azrael as
Abel took on the mountainous mercenary
he had ducked out of the way of an
oncoming swipe rolling between the
wrestler's legs in an open stance having
outflanked Bane before he had a chance
to turn around and face him Abel jumped
outwards a pair of his black reflective
swords in hand slashing through both the
air he severed the tubes on Bane's back
part of a harness designed to pump the
Venom chemical into his body and enhance
his strength sickly green fluids spewed
from the pipes with Bane reaching his
muscular arms behind him fumbling with
the mechanism desperately trying to
repair the device that kept his body
strong it was too late the Luchador
dropped to his knees and collapsed
defeated as Abel stood over him with his
swords in hand you can come out now bat
he called up to the ceiling by now you
have no doubt guessing that I am not
here for this one it's you they sent me
to find never want to charge headfirst
into a fight without fight Batman
dropped a smoke palette it burst as it
made contact with a concrete floor below
filling the area around able with a
heavy gray fog that was impossible for
the warrior to see through a trio of
sharp tip batarangs came spinning
through the air Abel barely had a chance
to see them coming in time to block them
with his swords only to be caught off
guard as an attack struck him from
behind dropping from above Batman landed
a devastating gliding kick knocking Abel
to the ground the Barbarian rolled over
angered at the outmaneuver as Batman
stood casting a towering pointy-eared
Shadow over him who are you Batman
demanded in the Deep authoritarian voice
of a grizzled veteran vigilante I am
known by many names the man replied the
detective taking note of his distinctive
Middle Eastern accent you will call me
Abel the man who will be your undoing
tell me who sent you the Dark Knight
retorted adding or else able chuckled
dryly before swinging one of his swords
downwards blocking it with his gauntlets
Batman trapped the blade between the row
of claws on his forearms before using
them to snap the weapon in two just as
Abel went to stab at him with his other
one The Dark Knight spun out of the way
grabbing his opponent's hand and guiding
the weapon away in a smooth Parry
telling of his years of martial arts
training but with both hands holding
Abel's attack Aloft Batman couldn't
prevent the barbarian from pulling yet
another blade from his pocket Dimension
with a slash from a smaller knife Abel
cleaved open the gray and black costume
that the cape Crusader wore causing him
a serious injury grunting in pain Batman
head-butted Abel Square in the nose
causing him to reel back still chuckling
at the tenacity of his Target impressive
able mused the foundation sent me here
to kill you I wasn't expecting to find
such a worthy adversary he slowly
lowered his swords while Batman kept his
fists raised in a fighting stance I will
not be their puppet you and I are both
Warriors The Barbarians stated I'm not a
killer Batman argued perhaps but you are
a fighter and a fighting man does not
deserve to be killed like a sheep at the
behest of cowards and fools you deserve
a Warrior's death Abel replied two hours
from now midnight we meet atop the
tallest building in this wretched City
there and then that is when you die at
my hand with that Abel turned and walked
away Batman thought about going after
him tackling him to the ground and
restraining him but he was still wounded
he needed time to recuperate I checked
the record sir there's no mention of any
metahuman with the power to create
weapons on either the Argus or Star Labs
databases Alfred explained over Batman's
earpiece after a quick Retreat to the
cave to tend to his injury Bruce was
already racing back out into the night
careening streets of Gotham in the
Batmobile what about the foundation that
Abel mentioned he asked Alfred not much
like either there master Bruce his
faithful Butler answered there is one
mention of an organization called the
SCP Foundation in an old August document
but the majority of the file has been
redacted the only reference to it is an
addendum that someone must have
forgotten to remove good work Alfred
Batman responded there's only one person
in the city who might be able to give me
more information oh heavens you don't
mean who else has an act for knowing too
much the cell was quiet lit only by the
low flickering of fluorescent bulbs that
hung from the ceiling of Arkham Asylum
it had been hours since the guards had
called for the inmates to go to bed
although they were no less alert any one
of them could break out at any time and
there was one who'd been waiting for his
chance rather patiently riddle me this
Edward said aloud aware of a figure
approaching his cell I am always around
but unseen I'm often avoid did but never
outrun I could find you at the end of
the road or even the next corner what am
I death Batman answered monotonously to
what do I owe the pleasure Dark Knight
The Riddler asked I need information the
cape Crusader replied and you've got
more than your fair share after a decade
of rivalry the detective decides to come
crawling to me for answers to offer some
recognition of my Brilliance not
Brilliance Edward persistence he
corrected
your cheerias ever the SCP Foundation
what do you know he peered over the rim
of his glasses offering Batman a wry
smile if you know me you'll want to
share me if you share me I'll be gone
what am I he asked a secret are they
certainly are Edward exploded with
laughter the foundation are an art Bunch
they'd even make some of the patients
here at good old Arkham seem sane by
comparison think of them as the resident
experts in unusual phenomena anomalies
they call them the maniac obsessed with
Mind Games explained they are everywhere
all across the world an organization
older and with more reach than any
you've encountered you know me oh my the
things they have locked away monsters
that would scare even you Batman how do
I know this isn't one of your delusions
Riddler Batman barked banging a fist
against the bars to intimidate his
Nemesis don't insult me Dark Knight you
you and I both know that you wouldn't
have come to see me if you were going to
disbelieve what I had to say the Riddler
yelled and mark my words if the
foundation as it sights on you well
riddle me this already Batman had turned
and started walking away down the
corridor my inventor doesn't want me the
man who bought me won't need me and the
man who needs doesn't know it what am I
the Dark Knight paused a few feet from
the cell a coffin it could all be a
trickster Alfred urged as Bruce Departed
the Asylum Edward nashton is hardly a
reliable source of information he has a
compulsion to always prove himself as
the smartest to always be right Batman
replied what I still can't understand is
why this Foundation would Send Abel to
kill me what's the connection between
them and me perhaps Master Bruce it's
less what connects you and more how you
could be an obstacle to them the butler
reasoned if this Foundation are experts
in unusual phenomena then there are an
abundance of such things here in Gotham
everything from the copious super
criminals to the giant coin here in the
bat cave and with me out of the way
Batman began to catch on they'd have
free reign Alfred finished the sentence
in sending a Madman to kill you it's
clear they didn't come to play fair sir
the clock tower in the middle of Gotham
let out an ominous bomb long marking the
approach of midnight the neither will I
Batman replied Abel had been waiting
atop the roof of a skyscraper the name
Wayne Enterprises emblazoned on its
front it was almost midnight there were
minutes left but the barbarian was still
confident the bat would show he could
almost taste the adrenaline of their
looming battle anticipating their final
showdown Abel could hardly wait to have
a worthy opponent to best in combat the
sound of some kind of advanced aircraft
whooshed overhead and the barbaric
Warrior craned his neck upwards soaring
above was the Bat Plane set against the
backdrop of the night sky with a single
beam of light reaching up into the
clouds projecting the dark Knight's
Insignia above the bat signal
parachuting down Batman had donned a
heavily armored battle suit over his
costume it originally designed it to go
toe-to-toe with Superman encased his
closest Ally ever went rogue but the
Armor's bulkier plating would easily be
more resistant to the Ferocious damage
Abel could dish out he landed on the
rooftop with a thud as Abel geared in
disgust coward he's spat you are not the
honorable fighter I miss took you for
just another Pretender like that
Luchador giving yourself an advantage
rather than relying on your skill are
you so afraid of me that you'd encase
yourself in armor are you afraid that
you'll lose Batman replied calmly
roaring in Anger Abel charged towards
Batman pulling a fresh pair of swords
from his pocket Dimension he swung the
blades through the air only for them to
clang off the thick plating protecting
the Caped Crusader's arms as he lifted
his gauntlets to block the incoming
attacks immediately feral bloodthirsty
rage on his face Babel swiped again this
time directing his weapon to a tiny Gap
where Batman's helmet meant the rest of
his suit at the neck the sword stayed
locked between the armor only for Batman
to pull back and launch a devastating
punch that sent Abel's staggering back I
built this suit to survive hits from a
Kryptonian trust me you won't even
scratch it Batman declared give it up
Abel walk away tell the foundation to
stay out of Gotham seeing red noticing
one of his weapons was still stuck at
the joint in Batman's armor Abel let out
a mighty yell and ran towards his
adversary stomping forward to clash with
him head on Batman started moving as
fast as the bulky bat suit would allow
him but moments before the pair of them
collided Abel dropped skidding along the
rooftop under Batman's legs using the
size and weight of his opponent's armor
to his Advantage just like he had done
with Bane earlier before Batman had a
chance to turn around Abel leaped onto
his feet and grabbed his cape pulling
the Dark Knight over and causing his
heavy armor to topple Batman clattered
down onto his back and Abel grip the
sword that had gotten stuck with one
hand gripping the bat by his cape the
Barbarian used the other to grab his
weapon trying to lever off his
opponent's protective helmet struggling
to get himself free Batman reached for
his belt throwing a barrage of batarangs
that spun through the air only to turn
and strike Abel in the chest he barely
registered the impact shrugging off the
projectiles as if they were made of
paper you cannot win even if you could
best me I always come back evil grunted
feeling his sword breaking through the
joint in Batman's armor I am able I am
Immortal but underneath all your tools
and tricks you are nothing but a man now
do what men do and die a sudden winding
blow struck able Square in the chest
Batman had activated the heartbeat
sensors in his helmet's eyepieces and
sent both his armor-plated fists
rocketing upwards connecting with the
barbarian's heart reeling Abel staggered
back trying to catch his breath as
Batman stood to his feet the hulking
unmistakable silhouette towering over
the immortal Warrior I'm not just a man
he growled I am Vengeance bam his words
were punctuated by another devastating
punch to the same spot I am the Knight
pow once more The Dark Knight struck
Abel in the heart sending him closer to
the edge of the roof I am Batman A
thundercrack Rang out as Abel looked up
wheezing at his adversary you you will
not kill me back he rasped no I won't
Batman answered leaning in close you
always come back with a final uppercut
he knocked Abel over the ledge sending
the Barbarian careening down into the
Gotham Reservoir below despite being
exhausted from their encounter Batman
scoured the reservoir for any signs of
Abel's remains he couldn't find anything
there was no body but Something Told The
Dark Knight that the undying Barbarian
would be back from a distant rooftop a
pair of foundation operatives were
watching through night vision scopes
well that seemed a little excessive one
remarked to the other didn't think he
was the type to show off but I don't
think he was showing off the other
replied I think that was a warning now
go and check out Deadpool vs scp-682 the
hard to destroy reptile and as cpu073
and scp-076 Kane vs able for more badass
battles from SCP explained